hi i'm steven drucker i'm a partner and
research manager
of the microsoft vita group which stands
for visualization
and interactive data analytics i've been
here at microsoft research for almost 25
years
so it's uh really exciting to be able to
show you some of the things that i've
been working on
so uh this talk is about data
visualization and uh really it kind of
comes from the fact that
these days we're inundated with data
we're drowning with data there's
there's over 5 billion videos that are
watched a day on youtube there are
350 million photos per day this was in
2017 so it keeps on going up
so what you know what do you do with
this well
it really presents an opportunity and
you're seeing data science
emerging as a a field of research
and uh jobs are doing it in fact job
trends and data scientists is one of the
fastest growing areas of jobs
and it keeps on going up uh you look at
quotes from
prominent researchers and media and
saying that we're entering this new
world where data is as important as
software
um you're seeing that folks are saying
uh
that the sexy job in the next 10 years
will be uh for statisticians
and uh you know this is uh from hal
varian the chief economist at google
and says you know people thought he was
joking but you know who thought that
computer engineers were going to be the
sexy job
so this is clearly an opportunity lots
of attention is being paid
towards machine learning and data
science but really
where do you start um there's so many
different ways to approach this
and different backgrounds and i'm
approaching this
from my background as a human
interaction researcher
and there's a very very simple you know
from 1988 there was this idea that if
humans are interacting with computers
they need to figure out what's going on
in the computer
and they need to figure out how they can
impact that
interaction this is called the gulf of
evaluation execution
so this is fundamental to all sorts of
human computer interaction
but uh what how do you actually do that
when you're interacting with data
so the key in my view is by using
visualization to help bridge that gap
so having a representation of that data
lets people understand and control
the the things that they're trying to
control so
that's what data visualization is it's
been around for a long time there's all
sorts of historical references going
back
uh over 200 years there's
famous representations of this in the
data you can go look up some of these
references in here
but arguably and there's been some
recently uh published material elijah
meeks said that
arguably 2019 is the year visualization
became mainstream you're seeing this
partly because
we're becoming more visual as a people
where we're or and
politic politics is doing it i'll do
some political examples later
and uh visualization is completely in
the public domain so really being able
to understand this a little bit better
and understand some of the nuances that
go into this
is what this talk is about so first of
all what is data visualization
and uh here there's a definition you can
see there it's the art and science of
representing
abstract information uh and that's
really important
uh in an interactive visual form that
enables people to more easily gain
insights through the perceptual and
cognitive capabilities now that's a
mouthful
but we can kind of take this apart and
look at some of the basics of data
visualization
to kind of understand what's really
going on with that
so here's some some basics um a lot of
people say okay look you know i
i've seen tables of numbers i've got
stats i uh you know
why do i need a picture of this well if
you've got stats you might know things
like um
here these table of numbers happens to
be that all of these groups have
the same exact mean the same exact
variance of the x and the same
exact variance of the y uh same
correlation you know
what what else do i need to know well
when you put up a simple picture
you can see each of these pictures is
very different
one shows a trend that's moving upwards
with a little bit of variation
the other shows something that's trended
as was going upwards and going downwards
one showing as a very very exact trend
with one single outlier
and the other showing something that's
really all around one number
and with one outlier so again seeing
that picture
really makes a difference and in fact
it's not just
these things you could actually have all
sorts of things with that same mean same
uh mean of x mean y same correlation and
get a very different picture so for
instance
there's the data source which is the
same mean and x the same mean and y
and yet it clearly is very different so
it's really important
to kind of be able to look at these
things before you start saying i
understand the stats
having that picture makes a difference
now there have been lots of books i i
picked pre
three prominent books here that you can
look up about this about how you do good
visualization what's visualization
research
but again you don't need to necessarily
delve down completely
you just need to kind of understand some
of the basics about this so here
here's one term called pre-attentive
processing which is a fundamental part
of visualization
and you can see as an example here's a
bunch of threes and i'm going to ask you
how many threes do you count in these
bunch of numbers
you know you might say oh three four
well if i highlight them like this
it pops out that's because we notice
those numbers
now now it's good that i highlight these
things correctly
because if i actually didn't if i missed
a three and show that you would say oh
there were
there were three threes that i saw when
there was actually four so it's really
important that we're honest we do it
well and accurately because you can
mislead and that's that's another trend
that goes on in this
but that pre-attentive processing really
helps us see things quicker so here's an
example just very simply which is that
you look at these and you pop out what's
the difference between those two things
you don't have to look at all those
individual circles one at a time
one pops out because of the color we
pre-attentively focus on color
color is not the only thing we also
pre-attentively focus on other things
what's the difference between these
you should see that's the red circle on
the right and uh you know
that we noticed that you didn't have to
scan through that whole thing
however these things are complicated
when you combine those two situations
it gets much harder you actually now
have to scan and look at all these
things and experiments have done and
they've measured how the reaction time
is they see that this takes a linear
amount of time
to see that there was a red circle on
the left side and not on the right side
okay there are lots of pre-attentive
cues and this is something studied in
psychophysics and you can look at all
these things and
we use these as sources of
of design ideas to do visualizations and
you'll see that later on
now preattentive cues aren't the only
part of
visualization another really important
part is how well
we measure comparisons so how many
how much bigger is that right circle to
the left circle
any guesses five times six times seven
times eight times nine
you know it's really hard to tell so we
can guess
second guesses you usually do a survey
um
now how about this how much longer is
the
wide bar from the smaller bar
turns out those were exactly the same
and it was
seven times if we kind of look at this
this way you can see that there were
seven circles that kind of make up that
small circle
um and then for this again seven of
these to make up those small ones
but people do much better at
understanding that length
rather than the area and in fact there
have been studies where we've ranked
how well people perceive these things
and this is a lot of what research goes
on in this
is what we can see that we're much more
accurate judging positions
uh our links than slopes and volumes are
really tough for us to judge
but these are kinds of some of these
experiments
that help us understand how to encode
information in ways that people can
gain insights from that so does that
mean that we
kind of now know that there's a single
best representation
you get some data and now oh um well let
me show it well
obviously not it really depends on what
you're trying to communicate
so as i mentioned before you know
politics is is replete
with people trying to communicate
information so there was a a bunch of
years back when obama was running for
reelection that there was actually an
argument with data that was going on in
the media it was kind of
fascinating to watch people take the
same exact data and present in very
different ways
there was first this graph that that
came out to say that the moment that
obama came to office
things turned around you can see this
directly read down there oh bad you know
all of a sudden things start to improve
well it's really kind of interesting
because
it was the choice of what they were
showing here this was actually job
losses and job
creations so it wasn't the absolute
number of jobs
it was as things turned around but there
were still jobs being
uh you know there was still a lot lots
fewer jobs than before
so there was a response to that where
they show this in a different way they
show oh wow look
jobs haven't recovered at all and
previously they were covered in the same
period of time
another way of looking the same data
that shows a very different point of
view
well there was a response to that saying
well yeah fine but
things were going up coming into this
administration and then they turned
around going
the wrong the different direction and
all of a sudden things return this and
this is only a half year so it's okay
so you go back and forth well fine now
this is all complicated let's just show
the
overall unemployment rate during new
year's years another way of
breaking out that same data and you see
a very different answer
so it's like well let's delve down this
into a little bit more detail
let's look at all the last few
presidents so we can see
how these kind of go and every time
there's been a
democrat a blue one things have gone
down and every time there's been a
republican one unemployment has gone up
so another way of looking at that well
yeah but fine let's look look how bad
things were under this last um
administration you know look how much
worse things got there bigger context
well let's actually put an even bigger
context this is what that same curve
was looking like before and this was
what the recession
the great depression looked like so
again these are different ways of
looking at
same data slicing it differently
representing it differently
to put out different arguments and
that's really important because the
representation that you're choosing
can help make your point very
differently so again there's some other
political content
we can actually look at you know the 100
days unemployment rates under different
presidents
and you can see again this is similar to
one of the other ones but this is often
featured but
is the hundred first hundred days really
the right thing to be looking at
for a president really you want to be
looking at the entire term you want to
look at some of the other things
even the choice of color can make a very
big difference
so this is the 2016 election and we'll
come back to that a little bit later
um and you can say okay you know look
how red everything is
well it turns out that we are sensitive
to colors in different ways
and if you actually show them with equal
saturation
you end up seeing uh you know a very
different picture
just with the same numbers and even that
is somewhat misleading because
what is showing here really is the
square footage of people that have voted
for the president
so this was a a um a picture that was
put out by
the um uh the trump administration
saying oh you know look look how
overwhelmingly
um trump was elected by but then there
was a response
to that taking that same data and saying
actually you know that's square footage
we don't really care about square
footage let's actually size each of
those areas
by how many people were voting in those
areas and transforming that and you can
see that
same essential data but a very different
view
now you're seeing you know where were
there people where were they
concentrated
and how did people vote again
sometimes people ask what is right
they're both
right they're both representing
different things you have to think about
what you should be
paying attention to and that's part of
what this whole talk is about is that
you need to be able to know what you're
seeing and know what the the
the potential deception is in order for
you to skeptically inquire to do that
okay so the yeah i'm not the only person
talking about that there's even a book
about this and and there's lying with
statistics and there's even
uh recently a book by alberto cairo
about uh lying with charts and
visualizations
and in fact sometimes there's
intentional deception
like for instance there's there's this
graph that came out a little while ago
that shows the number of abortions and
how they've gone up versus the number of
cancer
screenings at planned parenthood well
one of the problems about this graph
is that it was actually intentionally
deceptive because you're putting
um two very different numbers on the
same axis when you actually put this on
the common axis this is actually what it
looks like
so that was intentionally put out to
disease
um sometimes there's also there was a
recent debate about climate change about
how if we look at this
in terms of the amount of degrees that
have grown uh that have changed since
the 1880s
it's hardly anything you can see that
that line is almost flat
well there's a question about whether we
should be using
zero because especially in temperature
zero is kind of arbitrary there's
absolute zero there's zero and
fahrenheit zero and celsius there's all
sorts of other things
if you actually really want to look at
that trend you can just kind of look in
on that trend you can look at
how much it's gone up from 1920s till
now
so again a different slice of the data
emphasizing different things can make a
big difference again
sometimes that's intentional sometimes
it might not be intentional
so it's not even just the representation
that we're using
it's how we analyze the data so uh 538
is a
a great um blog that often features data
visualizations as part of this
and they showed actually that if you
analyze this data
and say does the economy do better under
the republicans of the democrats
depending upon what you mean by those
statements you can get completely
different answers
you can get if you choose it does that
mean governors does that mean the
president does that mean congress
uh the house of representatives senate
does it mean
unemployment does it mean inflation does
it mean gdp
if you choose different combinations of
these things you can get different
results in each of those examples
so um this is one way where it's
positive it's a publishable result this
is the way it's almost publishable
the other direction so so you can
actually sit there and there's a site
you can try it out for yourself to see
those things
and one of the things they did on the
site was that they found that if they
gave the same data
to 29 different research things in this
case it was about
bias and soccer teams and whether there
were more red cards given to
dark-skinned players or not they
analyzed the data by 29 different
research
teams and they found this variety of
different responses
and most of them are kind of greek a
couple outliers
uh but you're seeing that it really
helps to actually analyze this from
many different points of view so
there's this whole potential that if you
do this analysis you might end up
deceiving yourself
so this is a great example from from uh
xkcd comic where um someone comes
and says you know i think that there's a
link between jelly beans and acne
but when they do that analysis you know
it turns out that
the analysis didn't come out that there
was any link but then they say well
maybe it's only a certain color let's
try purple jelly beans let's try
red jelly beans and they keep on trying
different kinds of jelly beans until
you know lo and behold one of these
green jelly beans right here
um wow there's a significant result
there when we sliced it this way we got
different results
so what do they do oh this is
sensational let's publish this
let's do this yeast now it might have
been that they were trying to deceive
others with this
but maybe they were actually just doing
the wrong wrong kind of statistical
analysis when you slice this too many
times
you know there's a one in 20 chance that
you're going to get a significant result
from p is less than 0.05 and that's what
happens so that
you can deceive yourself if you're not
aware in doing the right things
um another way of doing self-deception
is thinking that causation and
correlation are the same this is this is
a great example from
google carlate where we look at the per
capita consumption of margarine and find
out that
it correlates 99.2 percent with the
divorce rate
in maine well if you do enough of these
trends and analyses and other things
you're going to find some
really weird aberrant correlations it
doesn't say that these things aren't
correlated but it does not
say that they're causally related and
again a lot of people will mind data
they see a pattern or cause a
a correlation and they'll think ah these
things must be related
so now i've used a lot of examples where
visualization
um is kind of confusing but
i really propose that visualization and
multiple views can help you
understand data so i'm going to show
some of these examples
particularly on on cases that uh people
don't
understand very well you know we don't
understand percentages we don't
understand
uh you know abaysian reasoning and all
sorts of things like that
so we're going to look at an example
from uh the uh
gender bias investigations in in
berkeley
uh in 1973. and um you know
one of the things is that visualization
can really help illuminate
uh the um uh what's going on here
so let's let's first look at the entire
population here
so here are all the uh
4 464 students that
apply for graduate school and we can
look at the overpopulation
and we can see how many were accepted in
uh blue and how many were rejected in
red
and okay you know it's about 40 were
accepted and then we can break that down
by gender
and as i said before um it looks like
there's some
bias way more percentage-wise
of the men were accepted than the women
so essentially
almost 50 of the men were accepted while
only uh 27 percent of the women were
accepted but something strange is
happening when we break this out
by department now we're starting to see
something strange
in every single department
the women were better than the men
or almost at parity so yeah right a
little closer
so wait if there seems to be bias
against women why are they doing so well
when we compare it to the departments
well the key here
to realize is that department a
and department b are accepting lots of
people department
e and f are accepting hardly any people
and when we look to see where the men
and where the women were applying
all the men were applying to apartment a
and department b
almost no women there and there were
more women
applying department e and f so what
you're seeing that yes where you see
these absolute numbers
um they did better percentage-wise than
the men
but there weren't that many absolute
numbers so being able to break this
apart by these statistics really helps
them understand this
and then you can see where this bias
comes from so
at first when i showed you that it
didn't make sense but actually breaking
it down seeing step-by-step
representations
really helps you understand that uh
there's another example
and this again happened in real life
when we were looking at
women that were getting breast cancer
screenings and
the facts are kind of laid out here that
one percent of the women over the age of
when they have a routine screening have
breast cancer
and that um eighty percent of the women
that will have breast cancer will get
positive mammograms
uh but uh nine point six percent of the
women uh without breast cancer will also
get positive mammograms that's called a
false positive rate
so um if a woman is tested positive
uh in the mammogram what's the
likelihood of she actually having cancer
doctors were asked this and you know you
can kind of think to yourself is it 0 30
thirty sixty sixty hundred
um this is really just bayes rule um
this is something from probability you
can look at and ninety-five percent of
the doctor's set was between seventy and
eighty percent when the actual number is
seven
point seven six percent what was
happening actually is with that there
were there were double mastectomies or
mastectomies that were occurring
when they did not need to partly because
it's like oh you've got a positive
screening when you got to do that
well looking at all that math is very
difficult to do
let's actually kind of look at the same
thing uh visually
so let's actually go and look at this
again a step-by-step explanation
here's 2 000 women that um have uh
cancer screening tests a mammogram test
and we look and say
you know this is how many women actually
would have cancer in the in this
population
okay you know just scattered about here
about one percent
all these numbers are for most
statistics and so you can see that
really it's a very small number
of those people so how many people then
would have
a positive mammogram you can see that
that
of those uh women that have cancer yeah
you know we do a lot there's also that
false negative
um about 9 percent again when we look at
these by percentage you can see that
eighty percent of the
women that don't have that do have
cancer have it and about nine point six
percent of them
do but you saw how many there were so
when we actually look at the absolute
numbers of these things
um this is how many positive results
they have this is how many negative
results
that they have of the mammogram we don't
get too many wrong
um that essentially don't have cancer
that have cancer but they had a positive
screening so they missed it so
we're gonna we only get missed four of
them um
and um but there's still all those false
negatives
so again that's why you're saying it's
really only the 7.5
percent that had it you know eight
percent or so so again when you look at
this
visually i mean it takes a couple times
to go through it and you can actually
try this online yourselves
but you can see ah now i'm really
understanding what's going on here
and again if you kind of look at this
randomly you can also see how many false
edges there are and you can even
represent this as this common
confusion matrix where you have false
positives uh
on the top left false negatives on the
uh
bottom right and um and the two
negatives
on the left and the true positives on
the right so again having these looked
at this way he's like now i understand
and you know if you actually broke it
down like this you might not be doing
false
mastectomies to a result of this here's
a
another example where
we try to look at bias in decision
making and now this is not an example
that
i i did this example that some
colleagues martin wahlberg and finan
vegas did
um where they were looking at two
different populations that might be
uh given a loan from a bank and
what happens is that um when it's very
easy to say oh here's a fica score here
here's a credit score
and if it's very clear that everybody
above a certain amount is going to repay
a loan
we just give those people a loan and
everybody below a certain amount it's
going to not repay
we deny those people alone problem is
that those populations often
overlap so they built an interactive
visualization of this
and let's switch to the interactive
visualization
and one of the nice things is that we
can actually say okay in this
population i can actually drag this
number around
and you can actually look at your profit
as you're going through this you can see
that
over uh in this corner right over here
you can see the profit sort of goes
up uh as i get the exact right point
right around there now if we give too
few loans
we're not giving enough loans we're not
making enough money if we give too many
people aren't uh here giving too few
loans if we give too many
then people don't repay them well that's
great there's no real argument there but
what happens if you have two different
populations
one population that might actually have
a different behavior pattern based upon
their credit scores
than the others so for instance if we
just want to now maximize the profit
we end up with two different thresholds
for those different populations
now suppose this population represents
race or
gender you will actually be denying
you're only going to give 50
of this population alone when you're
giving 61
of that population different loan so
there's all sorts of different
strategies that you can look at
this is the way to maximize profit and
sometimes banks might only think about
that
but you know you might want to say you
know we actually want to pile them all
together and use the same exact
threshold when you do so you actually
get quite a little
less profit but you might be fairer to
the populations
but that's actually not even that fair
because there might be a lot fewer of
one population the other
so there are other strategies like uh we
make sure that we give the same
uh a fraction of orange
and blue uh make sure the fractions are
same
or we give the same fraction of the
people that would actually pay off the
loans
these might be fairer but if you look at
all these different strategies it helps
you say
oh you know bias is a complicated issue
and if you're if you're looking
at maximizing profit you're looking at
all sorts of other things
there are a lot of considerations and
being able to do an interactive example
where you're dragging these things
around and seeing those results
really helps illuminate what's going on
any single representation of this
might have been a little bit harder to
see okay
so let's go back to here so
now we'll get to a project that um i've
worked on for a number of years
called sand dance and san anton is a
tool for helping you
look at multiple different
representations of of data
so let's let's open up sand dance and uh
it's available on
github and also all sorts of other
things you can actually extend to it and
we could just try it online and when
you're trying online you can either use
data that's up there already
um we'll use a couple data sets up there
or you can use your own data and that
data never gets uploaded it only
is looked at locally so you can try out
data it's completely private it never
gets uploaded anywhere
so let me actually set this up uh so
that i'm not showing color
so none and just look at your grid
so this this first uh data set is
some demographic data it also has some
voting data but we're not going to go
into the voting data
where every single one of these points
has a bunch of different fields
associated with it there are actually
about um 25 000 records and each of
these records is kind of like a county
it's sub-county it's called a
census designated place but it's a small
area with different populations so you
can see as i'm
hovering over each of these things you
can see you know this is in the state of
georgia
it's wheeler county it's the glenwood
city in wheeler county you can see how
many people
and all these things now when you look
at it this way uh this is kind of like
looking at a spreadsheet you're just
looking at a whole bunch of data
and it gets um you know there's no
patterns there no
nothing comes out and again
visualization is all about having
patterns come out
now uh one way that we can do it is we
can look at this as a scatter plot when
we look at a scatter plot you always saw
that
this you can actually see the united
states come out of this now this isn't a
map
this is just the longitude versus
latitude so there's projection issues
and everything
but you can always see okay yeah it's
very recognizably than in
the united states and i can switch to
say a column
and this essentially just a histogram by
longitude you can see
actually all the points just kind of
flowing up
and down into these different areas you
can see oh
i understand what a histogram is now
because it's really just counting up the
number of points in each of those
buckets
if i want to i can kind of make the
buckets i can make more buckets and
smaller buckets
and it starts it's kind of bucket size
there you can start
seeing even patterns across the united
states so for instance um
you know out here in the east coast if i
i look at that and i switch to scatter
plot you can see that the east coast
sticks out a fair amount main sticks out
and and you can see that you could also
see that
there's a lot fewer places here where
there's the rocky mountains in the
desert so you're already seeing patterns
emerge
across this just by looking at different
representations of this
and you can even see here that there's a
lot fewer points that's very sparsely
you know there's a lot fewer counties
there so one of the things i kind of
wanted to look at was some
uh economic data uh on this so what we
can do is it's good to be able to color
by things as we looked at before
color really pops out to us so i'm going
to color here
by the income and when we color by
income
you can see essentially most of the
country
is living at pretty low levels you can
see that
i don't see a lot of green here green
represents high income
and in fact you know in this view i
hardly see any at
all so if we want to we can go back to
that column plot
and again you can see maybe a little bit
around here which is the la area and the
seattle area and a couple of other
things uh
in the midwest again let's go back to
that uh scatter plot
and i'm gonna sort make sure that uh
income
shows up at the top and yeah again you
can see a little bit over here and
infection if we zoom in you can see a
little of those
spots over there so uh again
not much high income in fact if we do a
histogram
by income here let's actually um
let's do a column plot
and let's first sort by the income
and you can see in each of these spots
there's this little sliver of high
income
in each of those places not much most of
the places are at much lower income
and in fact if we do a histogram by
income over here
you'll see that most of the country is
down here
this is the median income and you're
seeing that a lot of the country is
living at or
near the poverty level and you know that
really shows
this this skew at least in counties um
one of the things i like to do is i like
to kind of look at the relationships
let's explore this a little bit more
so if we look at the scatter plot of
this we can
one of the things i like to look at is
the unemployment rates on this axis so
let's look at unemployment over here
now you're looking at at this curve
which is to say certainly the higher
income counties have
a lot less unemployment in general a lot
less variation too
so if we kind of look up here what about
these these are very high
unemployed counties that have very low
income and we can look at them so this
actually turns out that that's apache
county it's an indian reservation
except that this is coconino county
another indian reservation
and this is uh that's apache county a
different uh area
and this is navajo county every single
one of these
is um a different indian reservation so
it's like wow that
uh indian reservations are really you
know
have low income and high unemployment
that's a problem over there
well one of the things i was kind of
curious about was um how what about
income what about
um education does education help uh deal
with unemployment
so if we actually look at education
levels of each of these counties you'll
see that the curve looks very similar
it's very similar to income
here we're seeing higher education over
here higher unemployment
and we're also seeing income so now
something to me popped out when i looked
at this
i was noticing that off in this corner
here you're seeing
some very very educated places but you
see they're not
they're not all green there's some some
there's this red one
this one is that's not making much money
so it's curious
you know where was this place that is
very very educated and by educate we
mean
the percentage of the people that have a
bachelor's degree or higher
but they're not making much money so
when we look at this and hover over this
you can see it's stanford california
and it's where a lot of graduate
students are there they
already have their bachelor's degree
they're getting their graduates degree
they're not they're just living on a
stipend
now that's a single outlier is this
something like that
weird correlation or weird thing well
you know the next place i looked at was
was this place so that's forest home
i didn't know where forest home or
thompson's county was so if i
click on it we can actually get more
info on this we can just look this up
directly
in in ding so if i just look up tompkins
county here
it just goes directly to bing and you
you find out that um
it's the county seat of um where cornell
is
cornell university and uh ithaca college
so
it's a yet another college town so
okay now i'm starting to see some trends
so let me actually switch this from
education and unemployment to education
and income and then now this is your
typical trend you're seeing
upwards more education more income but
each of these points down here in this
corner here
turns out that's stanford as we looked
at before that was cornell
but every single one of these things
that's cornell as well
cornell cornell's spread out a lot of
different counties but then that's
that's swarthmore people might have
heard of that that's emory
uh we go down here and we see uh that's
umass
amherst so every single one of these
things down here
is a college town and to me what was
surprising is that college towns aren't
in this data they're not represented
directly in this data
but they are represented indirectly by
having high education and low income
and again i found that pattern because i
saw an outlier
and then i i came back uh to it
uh one of the things about sannis is uh
you can see already that i've used color
i've used different representations but
we could also use 3d
to help and sometimes 3d can help
elucidate different patterns in the data
so for instance if i switch to a
3d view here we can actually look at
here i've got income color by income
and on the z-axis i'm showing education
so you can see that
the education levels are sort of uh
where there's the higher income and you
know we already looked at that
before but we could also look at sort of
population density so if i if i look at
a stack view
you can see that this is where there's
very
dense areas on the east coast there and
even on the west coast and
wings and again you're seeing in those
high points
that's where you have high income levels
so each of these views
can help you and we can even rotate this
to be able to see it from different
angles
uh so it really can help you kind of get
clear notions of that data and you can
zoom in and
again get any information on on one of
these places
so for instance this is new york new
york and you can see that it's very very
high income level
there now let me switch to a completely
different data set it doesn't have to be
a data set
of of of demographics you can do it
doesn't even have to be a map-based
demographic
let's do one of the favorite data sets
that's often used
uh in machine learning the titanic data
set because it really
helps us um uh understand the data it's
used in machine learning all the time
and um i kind of let let's let's kind of
look at it right now what we're seeing
is we're seeing
um all 2207 people that were on the
titanic crew and passengers
and you can see how many survived the
green ones and how many didn't survive
you can see that that
only about a third of the people
survived and that's pretty daunting but
i i wanted to kind of look into this a
little bit more and see if
women and children um survive the time
tank for so so one of the things we can
do very quickly is i can kind of say
let's look at just the people that
survived
and i can isolate them so now we've
looked at just the people that are
survived
and then we can look at ed gender so i'm
going to switch to a column chart
and we can see that about the same
number of men
as women survived and when i saw this i
was like oh oh that that's terrible
they didn't pay attention you know it's
like only two more women than men
survived
um what's what's happening there well
again it's not just a single
representation
it's looking at at this in context so if
we actually look at the total number if
we stop filtering and look at the total
number of men and women that were on
this titanic
you can see that that there were many
more men and by percentage
by absolute numbers the same number but
by percentage men did pretty poorly but
that's not the full story
if we break this out by cabin class so
we can facet this by cabin class we can
see that in first class
women did really well only five women
died in second class
they did pretty well a few more died but
in third class about half the women died
now that um you know is pretty daunting
it helped to be a first class female but
if you're a third class female you
didn't do that well you still did much
much better than the man
but what about children so let's
actually look at the same sort of thing
by
uh children so if we if we instead of
choosing um
gender let's choose age
now when we look at age and we can
actually say let's bend this to be a
little bit more
you can actually kind of zoom in here
and you can look at in third class
one child uh in and first in uh
first class died no children in second
class died and third class about half
the
children died and i was like what's
going on in this thing
so one of the things you can do here is
you can click on this and
we can see who this person was uh and if
we actually look this person up there's
something called the encyclopedia
titanica we can look miss helen lorraine
allison up
and it turns out that she was traveling
with her mother brother and father
and the nurse took the brother off
earlier
but the parents didn't know that and
they vowed not to leave until they were
all together
so there's an example where they just
say again really tragic
and it also goes on to say that she was
the only child in first and second
classes to die but in third class um
something like 60
of the the um children died so again
very striking
uh other representations give other
meanings and i kind of like this because
it really helps humanize the data
so actually let's let's switch to a um
non-faceted view again
and let's look at something called a
tree map and here what i'm going to do
is i'm going to size this by how much
people paid
for their tickets and i'm going to color
this by
the cabin class that they're in okay
so here you're seeing that people in
first class
um paid a lot of money for their tickets
they're very large
and uh people in second class are orange
they paid less money people in third
class paid even less money and they're
green
makes sense but there were a couple of
outliers and aberrations that i found on
this data it's like
what's going on over here turns out that
over here
there's this single person that didn't
pay much money at all
but they ended up in first class so
again if we click through
i'm not going to actually click through
the encyclopedia titanic this time
but turns out that this person uh a um
a mr franz olof carlson turns out that
he was a captain on the line for
uh the the company that that did the
titanic and
there was a strike on a ship so they
gave him a first class ticket back
um on the titanic and he only had to pay
taxes which is why he shows up there at
all
unfortunately he's doubly unlucky he
didn't get to captain ship and he died
um there is one other person out here
this person over here
it's a mr alfred nornie and it turns out
that he
you can see that he paid about as much
as most of the
second class passengers uh and he didn't
like his cabin so he complained so on
the
ship he paid more money and it ended up
in first class which is why it's blue
and it turns out that because he
upgraded or maybe not because
but he ended up surviving the titanic so
there it helps to complain and you end
up surviving but one of the things i i
like about this representation is
that it actually helps humanize this
data you actually see that these are not
just statistics they're actually real
people and you can really
look at the stories and this links
between the representation of the people
and the story of the people
okay so um there's one of the things
that i've been doing right now is sort
of
telling you stories about the data and
this is kind of a trend
um about storytelling with data really
it's all about sort of giving context to
the data and trying to understand
the best way to present the data their
books about these i put these references
in there so you can look some of these
things up
and really a lot of what i've discovered
works well has been discovered before
and um
there's this uh nice uh site a map of
this is something called the cognitive
bias codex i'm not going to go into
all of this information uh here but you
can see that there's some
areas that i kind of unconsciously
addressed
by doing the stories about things having
too much information
or giving more meaning to the things so
it's these are some of the helpful
techniques that i found
um that uh that i used that you might
not even realize one of the things that
i did is i really tried to help you
understand the layout of that data i
showed you the the x-axis the y-axis
what's the meaning of these things
and so in order to help you understand
the data i've given you a context an
uh introduction to that data and then i
showed you an insight like the
the navajo uh the the indian
reservations so that you were kind of
comfortable understanding yeah i
understand high unemployment
uh low uh income yeah i understand that
that makes sense
and then i showed you an operation or an
anomaly that was
stanford and um it was like oh okay
i get it that makes sense to me but i
wanted to see
does that anomaly generalize is that
just a a
um you know a complete anomaly or is it
really a trend
so i changed my view i looked at all of
the anomalies that were all together
and then i saw that that insight
generalizes and these were all things
that i did step by step in this story
to help you understand the data and the
context of the data
and how it works and i think that's
really important to help you
understand things more completely so
um the next area is machine learning now
everybody
is very interested in machine learning
it's even you know people are hiring
even more in that area
calling it the elephant in the room and
you say okay you know
do i need visualization all do i need to
understand my
data if if i'll just plug it into a
machine and it'll give me the right
answer yeah
it just learns from all these different
examples why do i need to to
actually understand it so what should
visualization do in this context
well obviously i'm up here talking about
so i think it has a role
um there's a a real trend towards
helping create interpretable models
or interpreting existing models
why well people don't necessarily trust
machine learning you don't
trust why these things work so you need
to
help understand and explain them you
also need to understand what happens
when they go wrong you might need to
assign blame for insurance purposes it
might actually discover what's really
underlying oh and you saw sort of these
this uh analysis that i did of the
titanic
i'll show you a machine learning way of
doing that and that gives you a little
bit of a
deeper explanation of what's going on on
machine learning classification for who
survived and who different to survive
also if you're a machine learning
builder you need to improve your model
you need to figure out where
and finally probably one of the most
compelling reasons for companies these
days is
requirements under the data general data
protection regulation in europe
is that if you have any algorithmic
decision there needs to be
some sort of explanation for that so
where does visualization come in
again visualization is this bridge
between the raw data
the models the predictions and the user
and again that user could be the lay
user or it could be the expert user
so something you might have heard is
black box
models and white box models black box
models might be things like
uh neural nets that are really
complicated
and white box models are models that
might have you can open them up explain
them
and the the techniques that i'm going to
talk about here are
from a white box model that we looked at
a couple years back
there are also techniques for looking at
black box models but
uh in this case i just want to focus on
a little bit simpler to go
about this so in this case we're going
to be looking at some real estate data
lots of people buy houses and uh so so
people understand
uh that you know you might buy a house
and and yes there might be location
but there's also might be things like um
how many basements
how many bathrooms does it have how many
bedrooms does it have
what's the quality what's the year
there's all these different features
and all these features combined together
to give you
what the value of that house is and when
you look at it like that
it really is pretty simple if you if you
build a certain type of model
it's called a general additive model you
just add up all these features
so essentially this is just adding up
all these features
for house number 550 house number 550
sold for
uh we predict that it will sell for 190
um it's primarily um you know the the
negatives about this is that
uh it's a pretty small lot so um we
actually
from the overall average house for all
the houses
yeah it's it we took away a bunch we
took away 80 000
because it's a really small lot and um
it doesn't really have a
second floor square footage so we take
away some more money
but it might have um built fairly
recently and again
all of these things end up adding and
subtracting together
to to produce the final result it's
great simple visualization people can
understand that
you might have another house that sells
for a similar amount
and it turns out that you know it has a
curve that looks similar a small lot
area and a couple other things but
there's some differences and we can
actually highlight those differences
we can visualize those differences so if
we actually go down here and you can see
that
you know some of the big differences is
a little hard to see but uh the biggest
differences is was the overall quality
the overall quality for this model was
much better than the overall quality for
this model it was an eight versus a six
so this adds 22 000 and takes away
uh 14 000 from that one again that's an
explanation for why these two houses
were sold for different amounts
you can also look at the year it was
built that's another reason that
that offsets that so you can see that
these things
all help understand the model so we
built an interactive tool
and this interactive tool not only lets
us examine
you know these individual cases but it
looks at what's the trend
of overall quality and how much does
that impact
um the house the price house so let me
show you that last
demo here you can load a bunch of
different data sets
i'm going to load in the housing data
set here and you can see just what i was
looking at before
okay so again one of the nice things
about this is that
you can see that lot area makes a really
big difference
when we're a little bit there one more
when we're we're small there uh well
when it's a small honor but it starts to
make less and less of a difference
likewise as long as you've got
sufficient living area it seems fine
and then it starts going up in value
quite a bit more and again we can look
as i hover over these things you can see
that this particular house
house number let's just do house number
zero
you can see um is a relatively small lot
area
and therefore we take away a bunch of
money from the
predicted price but it's got uh it was
built fairly recently
so we can look at where the
let's see recent areas you can look at
all the different
graphs uh and we can look at the greater
living area
again it's a less living area um first
square footage
is um you know also negative and you can
look at all the different qualities and
one of the nice things i find is that we
can
say let's compare house numbers zero to
house number six
we can get both these curves you can see
exactly how they differ
and we can sort these in different areas
so you can see that the biggest
difference between this and that the
first house and second house
is the second house had a second floor
uh square footage
but it was smaller in the first floor
and had
um smaller basement and and a bunch of
other qualities
now i mentioned before that we can look
at the titanic data that we already
looked at
this again it's a common data set that's
looked at here
and we can say okay fair how much they
paid for their ticket
that makes a big difference as we go up
and up and up and up
we saw that age we didn't look at age
but you know age makes
a difference when you're really young
there's a better chance at surviving
when you're young
gender well uh if one is a female
females had a much higher chance of
surviving than men did
and you can see that right there cabin
class has a much higher chance
of surviving there so again if you pick
on any particular person you can say
okay
this person was a
you know third class uh female
um so you get a third class female they
paid very little for the ticket
and they ended up not surviving and
that's that's what happened
so again by looking at these models you
can get a better understanding of
how it's making the decision and that
really is important it's a role
of visualization in that okay so
let's kind of wrap this up with some of
the take-home messages
that i'd like to have one is as as
you're probably aware data science is
uh is key to the future of of
employment it's key the future of of a
lot of things and
to me and to many others visualization
is a crucial component for people
uh to understand uh data and to
communicate that data
so um doing so means that you should
take
some time and educate yourself a little
bit for appropriate skeptical inquiry if
someone shows you a representation you
take it as
reality or you really understand how did
they slice that data
how did they represent that data um i
need to do that for both someone
communicating with me
and if i'm trying to figure out how to
communicate that effectively
so one of my principles
is that multiple representations and
multiple statistics are important for
you getting a better and deeper
understanding of the data
just one point might have some problems
you want to understand that context
i feel that ml is wonderful but really
it should be focused on
augmenting human intelligence not
replacing it so
if that's the case if ml is being used
by
users we need to help bridge that gap
and again visualization is a key for
bridging that gap
um all those tools that i showed you uh
are available for you to try on your own
so uh you should go and try those
and um if you can also click uh if you
have more interest you can
click through to the site and i'll be
ready to answer questions uh whenever
you send them
thanks very much
hi uh thanks for watching this uh
webinar that was pre-recorded
uh this is stephen drucker i'm here live
to answer
some questions that have come up uh uh
thanks very much
uh for attending uh i had lots and lots
of questions and i tried to get to some
of them during the
presentation uh but um i wanted to
address
some in person here right now um
lots of people ask for resources to
learn more about visualization
and you can download the resources that
are included in this
this uh talk to be able to read some of
the books
there's also a number of different
websites uh that are out there uh one of
my favorites is uh by nathan yao called
flowing data
and he tends to collect uh both uh
behind a paid wall a lot of existing
resources and data sets to visualize
and also highlight some current work
that's going on
he's written a couple books that are
very nice intro books on how do you
visualize different types of information
and that was a
a trend that a lot of people are asking
uh you know how do they just visualize
is their best way to visualize
one one particularly interesting
question was why can't we just do this
an automated way
and in fact there are lots of things and
current work on chart recommendations
for a certain set of data
and you can do that in certain tools
right now including paid tools like
tableau and power bi
and even in excel you can
get chart recommendations for certain
data i think one of the points that i
was trying to make in this
presentation was that intention is an
important part of visual communication
and when you know what you want to
communicate that's part of how you
represent that data
and it's like in taking a picture a lot
of times you can do pretty well with
automatic settings and just take a
pretty good
picture but if you're really trying to
highlight the foreground
and uh blur the background there are
certain settings that you can use in the
cameras to do that
it's the same way with a visualization
if you're trying to tell a story you
need to be thinking about what are the
best ways for me to communicate this
now correspondingly i've often gotten
questions asked
questions about is there a right answer
what's the best way i hope i address
that and saying
look you know there are many ways of
showing the data and you really have to
think about all the different fields and
uh representations
uh and try to be fair and unbiased uh i
referred to alberto cairo a couple times
in
his book how charts lie he's got a
current
um trend in ethics and data journalism
and really talking about what are the
principles of ethics behind doing
data journalism properly
there were lots and lots of low-level
questions that people had you know
how do i use this in python what are
these tools how do they scale
um you know right now sand dance uh is
open source
um we can get to some of these uh
questions and we we've actually been
investigating putting them into
a python and notebooks so that you can
be looking at your data
in data frames for those people that
understand that and then visualize that
interactively
right away um we might be able to get to
some of those things and the nice thing
about being able to go into an open
source world is that
uh people can attack these things
themselves and so we're hoping that
there'll be a vibrant community of
people working on on tools
to to do just this um you know i i only
touch
a little bit on machine learning at the
end that's actually
uh a current trend in my own work is to
look at at ways that visualization can
be used
both for interpretable models white box
models black
models there was um one question about
our white box models more um inherently
interpretable
and there often is this trade-off
between
uh understandability of the model and
accuracy of the model and and we've been
looking and
and colleagues of mine who do machine
learning research have been looking
uh for these models and um
that gamut came out of of working with
one of those um models
and trying to help give tools to see
what people think
is interpretable and what's not
interpretable so
um right now it's great to have these
additive models they're fairly accurate
uh and they're they're fairly
interpretable
but we're looking at other ways to look
at um black box models and interpreting
those
both for end users like i reference the
gdpr
but also for model builders and giving
them
tools um i think those were
some of the big questions uh there
i think are a couple other things that
that we have time i i know that during
the talk the morph charts
uh link went down but i believe that
will be up and and you guys can try that
um again we've made a lot of these tools
available
uh to try both in isolation and within
other tools so for instance sand dance
itself works in
as a custom visual in power bi it also
works
in azure data studio as an extension and
visual
studio code is an extension and people
can take it and and make it its
extension for others there was questions
about incorporated get that into
r um
a few uh last remarks
um this is a big field and i try to
convey that
data science there's master's programs
you can look around online for
lots of resources for learning about
data science
right now those master's programs tend
to be two years i think two years is a
small fraction of what it takes to
really
learn about this because people are
learning everything from data
engineering where they're trying to
figure out how to save
data to um wrangling the data
so that they can get it in the form that
can be represented
to understanding and doing the
statistics to doing the graphics and the
design there are so many different
aspects of this
um this this brings up one question that
also came up quite often which was
you know how well do these data sets
deal with raw data and how much do they
need to pre-process the data and then
again that's a great question
you know colleagues have been looking at
better ways to wrangle that data in fact
it's been estimated that
more time is spent on trying to get your
data into shape to do machine learning
or to do visualization
then it actually takes to do the
visualization so building better tools
for shaping your data and changing your
data and filtering your data
are very important and most of these
tools that i've shown here
uh take fairly clean
tabular sets of data uh that's that's
both
morph charts and sand dams uh
the the other tools uh like gamut right
now um
you can use some online resources
i was using interpret ml and on the
project page you can see a reference to
that
that's a package put out by some of the
machine learning researchers here at
microsoft research
that help build these uh general
additive models or now they
they can also call them explainable
boosted machines
so on the website on the project you can
go to the live
demo of this and try out some of those
models that we built with this interpret
ml or you can build your own
and we'll be adding to that site to show
how you can build your own
and uh hopefully that you'll be able to
soon just
be able to take your own data and go
through the entire process of
having a model built fairly you know
transparently for you
and letting you view and understand the
data an important part
about machine learning is that it
actually to me
is just another part of understanding
data there's really nothing
magical about it it's just yet another
tool
to help you classify or do regressions
on your data
these this is an ongoing area i'm doing
research and many of my
colleagues both here at microsoft and
other places are doing research
there was one set of questions that are
dealing with
3d and holography and
things like hololens and immersive data
analytics and again this is an
active area of research um where people
are putting themselves in vr rigs and
looking at the data
it's kind of exciting and that everybody
would feel like oh i have this other
dimension of my data that i can
visualize how would these
um this equipment
help me visualize that data today
i think that there have been very few
examples of effective
immersive analytic visualization systems
uh
just partly because it's hard
we have limited attention and limited
ability to deal
with multiple dimensions and
often we're used to having static
visualizations explained to us
and except in cases where there's been a
strict
3d coordinate system like a map with
overlaying data onto that or
in bio biological imaging or
you know medical imaging or in
structural engineering
uh there hasn't been that much utility
found in looking at abstract data
there's a couple uh recent papers that
look at the effect of this and looking
at
network data because the network data
can be very complicated to visualize
and see and maybe the addition of 3d can
help
again these are ongoing research areas
one thing i didn't call out is that
there are a number of conferences
that deal with this kind of thing i come
from
a computer human interaction background
and
the main conference that deals with
innovations in this area
is sigh the special interest group on
computer human interaction
and that happens every year and there's
usually a visualization track in that
there's also an ieee conference called
viz that deals with
visual analytics information
visualization and scientific
visualization
and a lot of these papers are all
available and
while it might seem daunting to read
some of these papers
a lot of them are presented at a level
that that people can really
um understand and
read so i'm hoping that people can find
resources online
a lot of them are a search away um
you can look up data science and
visualization tools there were lots and
lots of questions about what's the best
open source tool and how do i use this
in python and pandas and
and there's there's lots of discussions
about that and uh i think you could just
click away
so um really just time for one last
question
and um i think that people are saying
you know where is this going
and uh this again is is a great
research area i i tried to leave this
off
on some of the bigger unsolved problems
i i think that the current debate about
machine learning is really interesting
and it's interesting both from
a technical standpoint and an ethical
standpoint
my point of view is that
machine learning can really help enhance
our interaction with
with the world and i don't like to see
computers replacing
people as far as jobs or as far as
um solving problems without the person
in the loop i i see it as an
augmentation for human capabilities
and finding the right ways and the right
things you do certainly
it might replace on certain tedious
tasks
you might get better and better about
choosing the right visualization
but i think there needs to be a dialogue
between
the computer systems and
the users that are essentially
mediated by smarter and smarter systems
but it really comes down to how do we
augment human capabilities
and that that's i think where a lot of
this work is going both in
helping build those tools and and how
you know how do we use this technology
in those tools
so um thank you very much for for tuning
in
and um that i
would uh look forward to having further
interactions with you
you